[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle formure d'envie de lecture je
vous retrouverai tous les 15 jours pour
vous faire part des nouveautés en
librairie aujourd'hui je reçois Laurent
Garin bonjour et Stéphanie ferrial tous
les deux libraire à la librairie le pavé
du canal librairie indépendante
et vous allez aujourd'hui nous faire
part nous faire partager vos choix votre
sélection de beaux livres à offrir pour
Noël ou à souffrir
alors on va commencer tout de suite avec
votre premier choix c'est c'est le vôtre
Laurent vous allez d'accord c'est un bel
ouvrage sur le château de Versailles qui
a été pris en photo par il y a 250
photographes officiels sur le château de
Versailles c'est un collectif ouais tout
à fait et donc ils ont eu portes
ouvertes sur l'ensemble du château donc
là ce sont des pièces qui sont
habituellement réservées aux personnels
uniquement enfin qui sont pas découverte
au public
cette fois-ci des pièces qui ne sont
normalement pas ouvertes au public et on
peut découvrir plein de pièces qui sont
normalement accès à tous les petits
passages secrets
du château qui sont habituellement voilà
pas de notre vision d'accord donc un bel
ouvrage et à chaque fois donc
uniquement avec un petit texte
explicatif finalement sur le cliché mais
vraiment très très courte la principale
intérêt de c'est vraiment la photo en
fait c'est vraiment le c'est ça qui vous
a vraiment et les photos sont très
belles et donc ouais c'est de fureter
comme ça à travers le château de voir
des nouvelles choses de découvrir des
pièces
dans le château à travers l'oeil de tous
ces photographes ont accès à qui ont
accès à l'exhaustivité du château et
donc on connaît tous certains clichés
enfin voilà on a tous le
les glaces enfin
certaines pièces qui sont connues de
tous mais là voilà c'est vraiment la
découverte d'un autre château qui est
normalement pas qui est pas vue par
personne finalement ça donne envie de
découvrir de nouvelles
nouvelles vision en tout cas du château
de Versailles
et Albin Michel avait déjà fait un
ouvrage il y a deux ans sur le les
jardins du château de Versailles donc
voilà c'est un peu la continuité sur une
très belle couverture de très beaux
papiers glacé ça fonctionne
Stéphanie est-ce que vous avez un autre
une autre notre choix oui moi j'ai eu un
gros coup de coeur pour le Dictionnaire
amoureux de la montagne d'accord chez
plomb d'abord moi j'aime beaucoup cette
collection elle est assez originale elle
permet de vagabonder sur un thème donné
un lieu ou une personne en général il
est toujours fait par un spécialiste
du rugby du 15 a fait suite de la
cuisine par exemple ou de cônes a fait
sur l'Europe là c'est Frédéric Thiriet
qui lui est un en fait à la base c'est
un avocat
l'ex-président de la fondation
de football effectivement il a été
pendant 14 ans ou 15 ans effectivement
président de la Ligue de football et
c'est un amoureux et c'est un amoureux
de la montagne voilà donc il est il y a
habité très longtemps et des dix ans il
est on a mis sur des skis enfin voilà et
c'est vrai que ce dictionnaire amoureux
c'est ça va plus loin c'est vraiment une
déclaration d'amour à la montagne donc
c'est toujours le même principe de A à Z
il y a une occurrence pour chaque lettre
voire même plusieurs occurrences pour
chacune des lettres là la montagne donc
il y a ces foisonnant c'est un des plus
gros et des plus denses d'ailleurs de la
collection c'est vrai mais tout y est
ils y sont tous des des guides rébusés
au-delà d'une promenade amoureuse il y
avait quelque chose d'assez passionnelle
également oui tout à fait parce que je
trouve qu'il va plus loin et c'est vrai
qu'il va jusqu'à dire qu'est-ce
qu'apporte la montagne qu'est-ce qu'elle
a la montagne et pourquoi est-ce que
voilà on y grimpe il y avait un roman
enfin le livre les conquérants inutiles
voilà c'est ça pourquoi est-ce qu'on y
va pourquoi est-ce que tout à fait même
danger et encore c'est plus l'homme qui
est dans qui se met souvent en danger la
montagne en elle-même il suffit de
l'appréhender fin de la une fois qu'on
l'a compris ce qu'on a le matériel qu'on
a la condition physique
voilà c'est pas elle qui va se mettre en
jeu c'est l'homme qui va plutôt s'y
mettre en danger moi je trouve
aussi magique mais aussi des drames
c'est ça mais aussi ce qu'apporte la
montagne sur le dépassement de soi sur
le dépassement de limite sur la quête de
soi sur voilà qu'est-ce que la montagne
d'ailleurs il y a une occurrence
montagne voilà donc ils y sont tous bien
sûr mais c'est aussi oui voilà qu'est-ce
qu'apporte la montagne et qu'est-ce
qu'elle a de danger mais qu'est-ce
qu'elle apporte aussi de
donc le Dictionnaire amoureux de la
montagne c'est chez plomb tout à fait et
on enchaîne tout de suite oui
dans cette collection il y a aussi le
Dictionnaire amoureux de Hergé d'Albert
voilà
donc dans les séries des cadeaux
Laurent est-ce qu'on continue avec vous
avec une autre une autre donc avec le
mur qui est un collectif parisien oui
qui veut dire alors tu veux dire
et qui ouvre en fait un mur à des
artistes
donc il y avait un premier ouvrage qui
en fait c'est sur 10 ans donc le premier
ouvrage faisait 2005-2010 celui-ci fait
2010-2015 et en fait ils alternent entre
un artiste français et un artiste
étranger et en fait il laisse ce mur là
ouvert environ deux semaines donc charge
l'artiste de faire ce qu'il sait faire
ce qu'il aime faire et c'est une vraie
page blanche qui est qui est laissée à
tous ces artistes de street art donc il
y a du graphe
standard il y a du collage il y a de la
photo enfin vraiment c'est
urbain dans toute sa splendeur à son
expression et voilà et c'est très bien
qu'il y a des
endroits comme ça sur Paris ou alors en
plus ça fait une tâche de d'huile parce
que ça pue ce principe là a pu se
répondre un peu en France
ils ont développé ce concept là donc tu
en as je crois à Montpellier je sais
qu'il y en a aussi en Asie ouais voilà
c'est ça et c'est très bien que on
laisse un peu de place pour l'art
contemporain enfin de la rue c'est une
très belle chose
de sa fonction première et voilà il y a
des très très belles choses quoi donc on
découvre on découvre vraiment beaucoup
de choses
avec des textes en français et en
anglais et en anglais tout à fait il y a
toujours ouais cette petite mise en
perspective de l'auteur de son œuvre et
de l'oeuvre enfin de son œuvre complète
et de l'oeuvre qu'il a produit là sur le
mur voilà donc il y a toujours ce petit
texte qui accompagne en plus l'oeuvre
qui explique un peu comment c'est arrivé
voilà la deuxième édition la deuxième
édition et ça se fait Sherman
on continue Stéphanie est-ce que vous
pouvez vous pouvez nous parler de votre
prochain notre choix c'était sur le beau
livre de la de la préhistoire voilà
qu'on a pas effectivement sur le plateau
fait par donc Marc Azema et Laurent
Brazier l'un étant un spécialiste de la
préhistoire et l'autre un historien
des livres sur la préhistoire il y en a
pléthore qu'est-ce qui te fait que ce
qui nous apporte celui-ci de nouveau
finalement
c'est-à-dire qu'on a à peu près 200
entrées différentes une par page on a un
texte et une photo toujours
correspondante et en fait ce que j'ai
aimé c'est ce sont les 200 grandes
étapes de la préhistoire mais de façon
vraiment internationale et non pas que
en France ou en Europe ou effectivement
est né quand même le berceau le berceau
humain et puis ce qui m'a plu c'est
qu'il y a eu enfin il y a beaucoup
beaucoup d'entrées artistiques
c'est-à-dire que effectivement je marque
qui est vraiment spécialiste de leur
pariétal et du coup qui s'est vraiment
penchée et d'ailleurs il termine avec la
slocate qu'il y a participé sur
effectivement sur d'essayer de chercher
à travers l'art à travers ce qu'on a
retrouvé alors aussi bien des poteries
aussi bien des statuettes aussi bien
alors surtout effectivement l'art enfin
les fresques essayez de déterminer mais
qui était nos ancêtres entre guillemets
et puis à quel moment finalement sont
nés tel et tel événement à quel moment
le langage est arrivé à quel moment les
premiers outils ont été vraiment 7
millions d'années à peu près
voilà et puis j'ai aimé le style aussi
c'est à dire que d'habitude
effectivement c'est vivre là parfois
peut être un peu Ré ou un peu trop
scientifique or là pas du tout c'est
tout à fait destiné à des tout à fait
des enfants enfin des enfants
effectivement l'enfance on s'intéresse
toujours beaucoup beaucoup à la
Préhistoire c'est vrai et finalement un
gamin peut tout à fait
des enfants par exemple parfaitement il
y a un vocabulaire un peu riche mais au
contraire ça va parce que en plus les
photos sont aussi très modernes je
trouve très actuelles donc du coup ça
donne quelque chose effectivement de
vivant et pas du tout de poussiéreux ou
de rébarbatif d'accord et puis aussi ce
que j'ai aimé c'est qu'il parle aussi du
métier de des archéologues et ça aussi
enfin voilà quels sont les techniques
utilisées maintenant pour effectivement
essayer de trouver de dater
le livre sur la préhistoire on a tous
dans nos bibliothèques
et puis ce qui est fascinant c'est qu'on
continue encore à apprendre des choses
et ça moi je trouve ça fascinante
tout à fait vraiment non c'est vraiment
très bien fait parfait
histoire chez donc de tout mailles à
Lascaux 4 voilà pour cette découverte et
on termine donc avec la dernière
sélection Laurent
intellectuelle en France qui est paru au
Seuil en deux volumes alors on parle un
gros dossier ouais mais très intéressant
on parle souvent des intellectuels
français enfin
voilà et là cet ouvrage en fait recense
tout ce qui a pu avoir en France de la
Révolution jusqu'à nos jours donc le
premier tome fait la révolution jusqu'à
14 siècle par Tom
et c'est pas tant une biographie pure de
différents intellectuels c'est vraiment
comment ils ont créé des mouvements
comment ça s'est inscrit dans la société
quels étaient un peu les impacts il y a
pu avoir sur la société civile comme
politique c'est pas uniquement on
détaille pas ce qu'a pu faire certains
grands intellectuels français c'est
vraiment comment ils se sont intercalés
les uns avec les autres quel mouvement
ils ont pu faire en France mais aussi au
niveau de l'Europe et au niveau mondial
voilà tout ça
personnalités
des mouvements de façon chronologique
mais donc on est plus sur des mouvements
politiques ou sociétales et comment ils
se sont inscrits sur nous nos
points national avec des échanges
intellectuels en Europe ou par en Europe
au niveau mondial aussi enfin les
échanges qu'il y a pu avoir avec les
États-Unis par exemple enfin voilà tout
ça est bien détaillé et ça nous permet
un peu de enfin voilà de se refaire une
idée de l'intellectuel français quoi
vis-à-vis de également
l'hégémonie parisienne j'imagine et la
lutte justement de la province vis-à-vis
de cette hégémonie parisienne ouais et
voilà et de comprendre aussi que c'est
pas autocentré sur Paris il y avait
aussi une vie intellectuelle très dense
tout autour de la France et qui avait
diffusé partout dans le monde donc voilà
un ouvrage vraiment très intéressant
pour cette sélection on a de plein de
bonnes idées pour pour les fêtes il nous
reste quelques jours et on va en
profiter pour va venir vous voir merci à
vous deux merci et à très bientôt à
bientôt au revoir
[Musique]